it is what it is huh that's that's what
it is
today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza I would like to
announce some new tour dates the dark
arts tour will be going to some cities
for the first time and returning to some
for some people that weren't able to get
tickets the first time I will be in
Vancouver Seattle Portland Boise San
Antonio Austin Tulsa Oklahoma City
Sacramento Las Vegas Memphis Atlanta
Louisville Biloxi Sayreville New Jersey
Bethlehem PA Oxon Hill Maryland and
that's that Washington DC area I know
that those shows the previous ones you
know there weren't a lot of tickets
available Cleveland
Indianapolis Grand Rapids Detroit gonna
go over there and my cousin a longneck
will be out there on that show with me
he'll be making a appearance second
cousin and Milwaukee and Madison
Wisconsin all of those it's the dark
arts towards the same mom you know it's
a set that I've been doing this year and
it involves some but I just want to let
you know what said it is so you know
when you come what to expect and those
tickets are all going on sale this
Tuesday with that date night Tuesday
April 30th at 10 a.m. local time so
whatever your local time is at 10 at 10
on your clock and 2:00 a.m. when the
sun's out then that's the time then you
can get those tickets you can use the
presale code onward onw ard and those
tickets are only available to our
listeners and to people that follow them
follow me on some social media platforms
and uh so that means that there for us
first so other people can't get them
other people that's not in our in our
little universe they can't get them yet
and that presale code again is
onward and and the the locales will be
on the websites you can see what
location but those are the cities and
thank you guys so much for your support
you know it's really amazing when I left
the comedy club this weekend in West
Palm Beach the lady came to me last
night they got a lady manager there and
she came to a hard-working lady and you
came she came to me and she said you
know your fans the the people that come
to your shows are so nice and I say yes
they are
and I said I'm happy to be one of a
member of that group we were just we're
trying our best that's what I told her
all right today's guest is a young guy
who I really admire and who honestly is
I don't know if there's any there's only
a couple people that make me laugh
harder and I think he's really just one
of the sweetest guys that I know and he
has a big heart I mean the guy probably
has nine aortas and unfortunately three
of them have been eaten Taco Bell and
haven't been sleeping much he's he just
got off set filming a film with David
Spade and and I'm happy to be able to
spend time with him today ladies and
gentlemen mr. Nick Swardson
[Music]
there's a woman who I know there is a
anymore these lies about I don't know
man yeah strapless dactyl son but she
looks legit
welcome to strap ganna stand baby saying
I got to and if you want them the right
next door I'm gonna get Michael Rapaport
to gum from under this [ __ ] table
dude gonna be pissed
let him get pissed bro in his mansion
dude what he can't buy is to mother
[ __ ] belt baby graduation let's take
on the roads guest starring starring
Nick Swardson Theo von
very nice there will be the HK you know
what I'm saying
give it a the Hong Kong what is it HK
I'm sorry okay there's something do a
guest spot later boy bye guys
bless your hearts bless your heart
thanks for coming in did that Velvets
[ __ ] up
huh that's really heavy Wow shit's legit
Oh
hefty got some girth on it huh yeah
that's some [ __ ] girth of a nation we
put them on blasts we just how can what
you call oh yeah read annoyed bro I
can't even believe those guys are and
were they I don't were they lovers or
what was their deal originally I can't
remember how they first got into the
game yeah I don't know how that link
happened did but it's somebody's got to
get to the bottom and top of it figure
out which ones which reel and no joke
brother sexual tension in there was I
mean you could cut it with just a piece
of string it was very easy to cut yeah
you could cut it with a string but the
string has balls on it
how [ __ ] thick it was and it seemed
like there was I don't know something I
it was just very alarming in there it
was fun watching Brennan try to remember
words it's good it was cool when you
watch his mind work it's it's like like
a baby elephant like falling to earth
and like just kind of looking around and
trying to just pick up what other humans
are doing yeah it's a fun process it is
people often liken it to watching like a
D like a deer take its first steps yeah
for sure you know but forever yeah and
the deer already worked out to get ready
for and it still can't walk yeah like it
already did three thousand push-ups and
I was like I'm gonna [ __ ] walk and it
just fails just fart I saw him and he's
just misguided too he I saw him doing
curls one time before a spelling
you know it's like yeah that's that's
bad dude it doesn't work he doesn't
realize that he just he over juices dude
Oh Brian doesn't help cuz he sees the
opposite yeah where Brian works down
yeah he tries to take his push-ups away
yeah he doing negatives good and brian's
lost a lot of weight in the past years
almost 30% of his body weight yeah he
lost he removed several bones oh yeah
yeah just look kind of thin out a little
bit ever since that last moon landing
you know he just hadn't been the same no
and then he modelled his face after it
saw the moon is like I gotta get that
permanently on my face Nicolas Wharton
is here today man sup good to see you
good you just made a movie you just made
a movie you were the lead in is that
right I made a talkie I was a co-lead to
my boy David Spade so yeah that was fun
we shot in Hawaii and I got a great tan
as you can tell he's still gay you have
a little bit of team a little bit of
color but not that you know I had to
stay out of the Sun that's not yes yes I
just had a son and I work out well
people were people were starting to yell
racial slur I mean you got pretty
bronzed didn't you yeah it got really
ugly man ya know the director was like
seriously said he had to stay I had to
stay out of the Sun so it wouldn't match
other shots and I thought that that
meant stay out of the Sun and the gym
yeah just combined to them I like that
yeah it was good yeah you know David's
appeared at all
you know I've recently got to know him
over the past year very unique guy yeah
he kind of keeps himself away he kind of
a lot of people like I was with him
somewhere and people thought he was
Macaulay Culkin and I thought that that
was uh that was kind of an interesting
moment in his career yeah that's pretty
interesting that or now or in the future
they're like a-you Macaulay Culkin and
fifty years ago
well Macaulay's age not well have you
seen him recently I do a bit on stage
about it because I was on my computer
and a pop-up thing happened it was like
celebrities that look like [ __ ] and they
had Macaulay Culkin yeah showed a
picture of him and you know what I mean
he's like 30 or something whatever the
[ __ ] it was but then they reference a
picture of him from home alone and I was
like what
can't reference that they're like that
look at him that now look what he
[ __ ] looks like I'm like yeah the
dude was nine whoo how do you reference
that you can't reference that again sup
what life has done to people in 30
[ __ ] years yeah unless you yeah yeah
how do you do that man it's like on you
can't keep up with yourself you can't
always look like you're nine no you can
try yeah or if I look like I was nine I
would just I would be like just hit me
with a brick or some steak me out
because something's gone horribly wrong
well you know they busted a guy and this
was in Indiana or it was probably just
Indiana cuz that yeah that's a lot of
[ __ ] off there but yeah sorry they
busted a guy there he was a adult and he
had like a some deficiency or something
and he was going to school at a middle
school and he was 31 years old right
right what's going on you hear something
here yeah I am it is cool it's like a
hype thing oats wrestling it's Joe Rogan
is it what we're next door in there in
the back of all of our heads of America
right now we're in I wouldn't be
surprised if Rogan did implant a chip
and I I know I'm just secretly just like
what's up man is high-fiving the chip in
your [ __ ] hand he just watches over
and it's [ __ ] Icicle but he just sits
in nude yeah I'm [ __ ] 40 different
stimulants just with third eye v i7 eyes
just [ __ ] you oh he dropped the
[ __ ] shock where the other day I was
walking behind him and a chakra fell
right out of his pocket oh my god and
I'd pick it up and give it to him dude I
have different times yeah I caught him
in the bathroom and his body was full on
from the movie cocoon when it was all
gold and shiny and you have to like look
away yeah he was like oh what the [ __ ]
dude
and he just floated away through the
wall oh wait that's right yeah I saw him
eating owl nuggets bro straight owl oh
dude hundred percent pure owl nuggets
eating him out of a [ __ ] bag uncooked
that's what he does man I saw him the
other day he was back to his comedy
start eating ferret sashimi oh yeah dude
I was like what that's not even a food
he I killed it with a crayon
yeah what the [ __ ] dude he had a [ __ ]
quart a fresh quarter Moonglow bro
oh my yeah just iridescent off the
[ __ ] moon bro yeah non liquid based
he told me like dude no rules that guy I
saw him take a grenade that had was just
filled with soil and just swallowed it
and [ __ ] detonated it and it was just
here soil from Egypt yeah I don't even
know if they have soil and it just
detonated and then all of a sudden it's
ab workout yeah his whole abs were like
perfect and then I [ __ ] a golden cat
ran out of his ass where was that
locally dude that was our in the middle
of the 405 freeway yeah I was not so he
does some of his best work on the 405
yeah no he's ledge wait who was from oh
I suck the Cystic Fibrosis right out of
a kid once oh my god he's a healer too
oh my god that makes sense dude yeah he
spit it right out of a window man it was
[ __ ] sexy too dude yeah that's sick
and just went out into the ether it's
just traveling went right into Cowan
yeah tell absorbs I feel like every kind
of disease and ailment and he processes
it and just lets it emit he's a liver
he's basically the liver
he's like Keith Richards and like a
pirate from like an old pirate that's
done some [ __ ] dirty [ __ ] yeah like a
part that's still out there sailing yeah
like milling around the harbour in st.
Petersburg just oh I think a Brian
Collins real name was John John dis
we're like that's too gnarly but you
know what's amazing is how many diseases
he's that he has and beats at the same
time yeah you know it's impressive I
mean he's coming on 300 years old dude
somebody said he has HD IV what is that
it's like thanks for though whatever it
is it's extra heavy AIDS bro you know
and no offense to anybody that is a ya
know if anybody else a it's that sucks
dude hang in there [ __ ] that
hang in there you know man is a
basketball team dude you know live your
dream yeah dreaming
McKey Mertzon man you just say yeah you
just did a movie with Spade so is that
yeah it was real was a real thing
do you enjoy like is that like your cuz
you don't do like a lot of televideo
MIDI central show a couple years ago and
you do a lot just from films now I've
done a lot of movies but I always
develop TV so the one show I sold was my
show up for 10 time so you can find on
itunes and like youtube and stuff but
it's hard to find and then I I always
develop a show every year and it's just
hard to sell so people don't realize
they just think it's easy so people are
like oh why don't you do another show
and I'm every year I try to sell a new
show and then you know people just don't
get it so it's like I'd ever every year
I develop a Shum pitching a new show
coming up the next couple of weeks and
you know it's just hard to get back on
because my brain is so [ __ ] weird bad
yeah excuse me that's how I pitch my
show you have a lot of bile it looks
like and you look like somebody that's
bow hey oh dude I'm the [ __ ] River by
going right through no ma'am yeah
[ __ ] book I'll daddy they call them
that says bile daddy or just have a show
called boiling out yeah and it's just me
regurgitating [ __ ] bile do that so
worse by the way for you guys who drink
out there guys and girls mm-hmm you know
I mean that's
I'm always do the bile but barf [ __ ]
rough dude when you get [ __ ] after it
that's especially when you're going on a
[ __ ] bender yeah and then you have
like [ __ ] bile and you just it's like
[ __ ] alien my boys are nasty you know
Simon ah be a good friend of ours we
always trade war stories of [ __ ]
partying and stuff of the by those of
you know now are you just like it's like
[ __ ] alien where the thing is like
and that's you though and you're coming
through your own something that's just
and it's just [ __ ] sucks and that
aftertaste bro it tastes like [ __ ]
Cancun in 1996 like did I [ __ ] do a
Valvoline shot last night [ __ ] did that
have Natalie Holloway at this bro bro
yeah it's [ __ ] burn after reading do
that but I feel like with partying it's
like I always like I'm trying to live up
to old times in my life like I can never
get to that level again as to when I was
like just off you know just [ __ ] up
babysitting animals [ __ ] living on my
friend's couch I just [ __ ] doing life
oh yeah I can't I mean people think that
I party all the time I don't I don't
really do drugs at all and I never was
really a big drug guy and but I was a
big drinker but I go through I haven't
drank in like two months
oh well yeah so it's like I detox I eat
really good and [ __ ] like that but it's
like healthier than I've ever seen your
eyes look bluer than ever yeah I'm alive
I'm [ __ ] alive dog yeah but there's a
lot of chat rooms you're not alive in a
lot of there's a lot of like Reddit
feeds where you have been deceased for a
while over yeah now I've clocked out
I've clocked out a couple of times now
it's funny because people s thing about
social media like I'll post pictures
because I like I'll go out to bars have
fun drink with people fans I mean I have
a blast when I'm like out and about and
like getting after hmm you know I mean
and then people take photos and we'll
have fun and laugh and [ __ ] and then
I'll post photos me like clearly having
fun and then paper like you look like
[ __ ] Gargamel's [ __ ] you know what
I mean like so I'm like well which guy
do you want
you know I'm clearly smiling and having
a good time why are you taking me down a
notch I didn't get married and have five
kids and live in a [ __ ] tundra and
yeah our Judge Judy on the [ __ ]
social media
[ __ ] you I'm [ __ ] 42 years old
dressed like I'm 13 I don't give a [ __ ]
I don't give it I can't drink my [ __ ]
fake tits off and bro would you ever get
fake tits and fill one with a mixer and
one with boots
oh dude if I make it to 70 the wheels
are coming off dude and then wheels are
coming on I'm taking my legs off getting
[ __ ] souped up wheels with rims 32
that's how I go around yeah I'm gonna
just [ __ ] gut it get after it just
straight from your Cossacks into some 32
yeah [ __ ] roll do
yeah go hard bro if you make it to seven
I just feel like 80 that's even pushing
it but it's like if you can do that I
mean I think you should just go for it
you know 80 is kind of loitering you
know what I'm saying like at 80 nobody's
like oh yeah grant like it's 70 people
are still engaging with ya you can still
do [ __ ] when you're some I don't know
what ages so I don't know what so who's
70 yeah I mean an example of 70 yeah who
say who's 80 right now Clint Eastwood's
84 I think [ __ ] so let's say you make it
like 90 but we don't even do they live
that long now I feel like you can die
from eating like Lunchables [ __ ]
crazy like oh yeah I had too many
Doritos he died like 43 like it [ __ ]
just takes you out there's no plagues
anymore that's the slow there should be
like a Dateline for just complete
[ __ ] ways that people died you know
people were wondering what was up with
Nathaniel right and there's a spin at
his house for two days he just choked on
a Cool Ranch to read you know yeah they
have a show like that's called the
thousand ways to die oh really yeah it's
how people died or how they wanna die
it's how people did die like weird ways
that people did die how do you die Nick
Swardson how do you die we ask a lot of
our guests I'd hear a lot of people
wouldn't have guessed or we have just
[ __ ] that pass through um how would
I die I don't know maybe I would want to
like I'd want to go out you know what I
mean like I'm you know I would want to
like crowd-surf and my 90's you know to
mean that like a [ __ ] Creed reunion
oh yeah yeah and they're singing like
can you take me higher and I'm 90 I can
barely [ __ ] do it I've to take the
wheels off my body yeah and then just
have them throw me and then at while I'm
in the air I'd shoot heroin in my eyes I
see something a little bit more engaging
for you though man I'm just let it rip
man I feel like I see you driving like a
party bus of [ __ ] youngsters that are
out for their first prom you know and
there is and all they have is a little
bit of bush light but you [ __ ] just
just limply leave a [ __ ] sack of
cocaine back there for the [ __ ] baby
yeah or just you know like
passive-aggressively right like like
roll the window down in this
like Burton like it flew in the window
right and so then the party gets [ __ ]
buck you know you have to bring other
people into my [ __ ] demos so this is
how I'm dying that's how you die so then
all right well there cardi and brother
going hard and you start to get a little
bit jealous cuz you're just a driver
dude you know I'm saying you're just
cruising a group of people overdo it
shitty [ __ ] almost closed
TJ ribs right and you're cruising over
there and finally you can't take it
anymore you pull over onto the side of
the interstate you know and you start
partying with them doing beer bongs but
beer bongs all of them the big hitters
you know right it's really showing off
you know some people are scared of us
hope you are still engaged but
thankfully you guys are in a zone where
their phones don't quite work right
right if you were supposed to pull like
over all the way outside of a tunnel but
you stayed in the tunnel a little bit
cuz you guys are in New Jersey and next
thing you know bro you guys know this
make sense you guys are living high on
the [ __ ] hog and like some boy and
girl are both losing their virginity and
you know in part and things that didn't
even know was going on dude right and
finally a [ __ ] semi truck carrying
fresh meats and produce just [ __ ]
grills you guys throw and since all yell
to heaven as a group okay I like the end
we're all just unified and then do what
does my heaven body go back to like how
I look now like I got like I'm at a prom
and [ __ ] ki everybody it looks like
yeah look at her Sherpa three flights of
stairs Indian [ __ ] that's perfect
I kind of like that my side death was a
bit I read that went viral that was
amazing about the trapeze artist with
diarrhea yeah that'd be a good way to go
out to just get up there just crush like
three days of tea bail
yeah and then maybe a [ __ ] then have
like a peanutbutter broccoli smoothie
important an omelet oh that are old
rotten oh yeah and then chug that but
then also lay in a hot like soak in a
sauna for a little bits here bodies
reals
you know yeah it's so there's Rhett to
go yeah you have 2% chance of holding
ins a [ __ ] warm pot of D yeah and
then just some [ __ ] scalding Ovaltine
oh crap I grab the [ __ ] trail please
[ __ ] bar I look at a picture of Bryan
Callen and I'm ready to go I set it off
yeah on the world stage
New Year's Eve New Year's Eve and candy
goes down there with her mouth open
Kathy Griffin's reporting and then it's
just game on so that's another option
there's a lot of options I realized this
reason I wanted to run this by oh yeah
so Theo and I we're friends were all
friends Callen everybody shop blah blah
all others crew you know and we all
roast each other to each other's faces
via text yeah
Tim Instagram all those social media we
have a blast and then I found this I
realized this long time ago I remember I
was a kid I would I was a small kid yeah
and so I always overcompensated by being
like weird and like goofy and I'm making
fun of people that's how I just got
along and I would get beat up and you
know as I got older it was almost like a
superpower where I would just inherently
just like rip on people and get laughs
but I didn't know how to control it so
it like kind of mean as a kid yeah and
so I just make fun of people and then as
I got older the point being is that now
like when we roast each other I'm so in
that like mindset so when I go home for
like Christmas dinner or Thanksgiving
there with my family I'm still on roast
mode they don't realize so I'll just
start lighting people up and Kathy uncle
Jeff no one's safe at the dinner table
yeah and no one's ready for it
everyone's I'm gonna soda like all right
how was your day I'm like how was your
[ __ ] day look at your [ __ ] hair
and that one's like what and I just I
always feel bad they're like I saved
enough to get my hair done I sold I sold
my photo album for me 400 years to buy
this those shoes and then it's just I
don't know do you experience that where
I just I can't turn it off my brain is
so [ __ ]
really I did I just do it all the time
and then so I did this on other people's
and they really help you bail out of
this shitty
on topic you let us into no I think this
is a good topic it's [ __ ] real - are
we able to turn off being funny well no
just like so I go on other people's
instagrams and I'll just start roasting
on your good attitude man you're some of
the lines you say are good so I did this
recently yeah my friend Kevin Love good
buddy money to pay for timbrels and from
Minnesota I don't know his Instagram and
he posted a photo of him at the beach
he's like flexing you know he's you know
is in shape I said the beach is happy
and I go you look like a bird that needs
to take a [ __ ]
and I commented got all these people
like el bruh [ __ ] you who the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you don't mean go wolves yeah and
I'm just like I just you know I
I know cabinets bussing is Wally
Szczerbiak til I die but some [ __ ]
yeah but people just get I don't know
you don't you don't experience that I
don't they can't especially in this day
and age and get love standing like a
Bertha has taken [ __ ] now like that's a
great row so just I was just bored and
sought cab and I was like I'll drop him
a line yeah I'm gonna give any friends
at the beach you look like the guy who
[ __ ] killed Natalie Holloway right
there I mean there's nobody there's like
one set of footprints going into this
Sandra this is [ __ ] your and Vander's
what I mean I love you so it's just
funny how people get so sensitive Sally
it's sensitive out there well I know
like even uh you know III had dinner
with your friend David Spade not long
ago right when he got back from y'all's
movie okay and he said that he had
commented on Kate Beckinsale's
did everybody gets to do a [ __ ] storm
[ __ ] Whitney like tweeted so she got
into a [ __ ] storm but David I commented
on Kate Beckinsale's Instagram and it
made the [ __ ] news what world are we
living into this shit's making the news
D'Elia come Albuquerque it's on the
Albuquerque news I've been to
Albuquerque there's a lot of other [ __ ]
that should be on the news Albuquerque
[ __ ] phone book of [ __ ] crimes
there look if there were four car
museums would have much of an industry
let's be honest dude beautiful people
though they're a lot of buried treasure
there that's a big thing a lot of
treasures I mean my family now
yeah I have nothing it's Albuquerque New
Mexico I like Santa Fe Santa Fe is nice
though but Albuquerque's basically Reno
in a nice hat
I mean Reno is the kind of place I would
give blood never take blood
you know I think you have an option
really you're going to take blood I was
on my last tour I did I went to Reno and
my bus pulled up to the casino and it
was like 2:00 in the afternoon and I
this is my hand to god I'm not joking I
got a tour bus to him I turn manager I
go hey I'm gonna get a bite and I like
walking I like just telling him chill
dude so I'm walking down the street
trying to find a place to eat this is
broad daylight and the eight to ten
people I saw in the street I was afraid
of really in the middle of the day and I
had a panic attack I was like oh look at
[ __ ] alright look at there's Rick
over there is stuff to no good everybody
just look like they were like how much
is that guy's eyes type of look like oh
just I was just fodder dude it was like
walking dead [ __ ] and I just beelined it
into some [ __ ] random OS something
died its Harambee country bro it seemed
like a lot of people they're [ __ ]
killing monkeys you know that's like
[ __ ] Temple of Doom [ __ ] where
they're just taking a dude's head with a
spoon a little hammer and just and just
[ __ ] nectar brain nectar a lot of
people just [ __ ] snuffleupagus over
there bro and I was on Reno 9-1-1
[Laughter]
if there's any missing children right
here I should run for mayor but yeah
that [ __ ] got crazy man and then they
barked at him that lady barked at him
you know I know it's funny I don't know
it's just funny but yeah it's weird it's
like where can you be funny these days I
just say whatever the [ __ ] yeah I mean
it's just funny to me people this saying
it's just like - I don't know let's just
try to move forward with like not taking
shits so like oh my god
but don't you repeat that the people
that do all that all that shit's like
disappearing brothers people's turning
in a straight Muppets you know like
nobody gives a [ __ ] about any of that
people just want to laugh and
a good time people are kind of getting
tired of it yeah well there's a reality
to it and you can't sustain like it's
just it's too much you know I mean you
can't be that like you just sanitized
were just like all right you can't do
CPU no you can't do CPR on somebody in a
restaurant anymore why cause if you hurt
him too many lawsuits coming back the
other way so I was at a place the other
day
because I was at a place in New Orleans
a while back and somebody got CPR right
and I loved that kind of [ __ ] dude
you're in the room you have a [ __ ]
lighter yeah you got four [ __ ] fresh
crab appetizers rolling on the table
dude and so he might die [ __ ] 11 feet
away from you bro it's like the UFC and
vogue and uh you know it's like the UFC
goes to Key West you know I'm saying
it's a [ __ ] exotic moment it's
exciting so this lady was you know
someone going well and her husband I
could tell in a beat heartbeat the
husband wasn't really interested in
saving her you know right he's like
what's going on he kept asked her like
six times and she you know I'm not good
at charades but I can obviously tell
what somebody keeps pointing at their
throat and not being able to breathe em
pointing it like shrimp on the table and
then pointing in their mouth he's like
what do you want you want me to order
something else you know he's like I
could just throw it out he's like he's
like future like like scapegoat whatever
just things that would make it seem like
he no dessert no dessert just trying to
[ __ ] buy his way out of it with the
game what do you mean I'm the problem
like he just started saying he's getting
into a fake argument
yeah that would hold up in court you
know yeah so then this dude if one guy
was pretty jacked up on some uppers bra
and he worked there at the place dude
and he was kind of like Italian but not
really Italian but just had done like so
much like probably like lean type of
drugs that lean you out and gotten so
much bad Sun that he looked Italian you
know yeah the kind of guy who looked
like he [ __ ] tried to buy like owned
a dolphin once I get it like in a in a
timeshare or something you know like a
dude that's been you know doing
basically doing cocaine a lot he rolls
over brah and he [ __ ]
he first of all this is craziest thing
I've ever seen he's gonna do the
Heimlich he starts to kind of do it he
can't really get a grip on the lady
takes
sure oh my god that is Oh bro he had and
I'm not joking a huge Linda Ronstadt on
his back right which is something you
don't see that much no you don't you
don't you've never seen it and pull up a
picture of Linda Ronstadt mine it's
beautiful young oh there she was kind of
a thicker uh Tiffany basically of her
time she was like a thick Cyndi Lauper
you know and let's get a picture over in
this well younger you have anything
younger this is basically right before
death there you go that's titty time
Ronstadt right there they used to call
her that boy which direction is the
North bro you know saying I'm a boss I
bet moss grows on the side of those
[ __ ] bro you know saying those things
are husky you got our haircut on a set
of spinal tap definitely dude so she got
her hair cut by a Slap Chop bro she
looks oh my god but anyway this dude who
takes his shirt off right so no dude I
can't eat if some guy who's high on
drugs has his shirt off in the room and
I swallow yeah it's like a it's like a
reflux that I have so he starts going in
on this lady and the shrimp eventually
shoots out and bro 9 minutes later
they're having dessert it's crazy how
quickly you forget that you were just
about to die right right but now I go
back here this a year later I'm there at
this place Pascal's Manali down there in
New Orleans and I said yeah I said dude
I remember the last time we were here
you guys had the little you know it's
kind of like Vegas and they do a little
show out front you know right I was like
you guys had that choking you know and
uh and he said yeah we can't do CPR
anymore because it's just too dangerous
so somebody's dying you just have to
like be there for you just clap I guess
try to like cheer him on and like at
least go like go go oh yeah more more
more animals just keep him more food
faster faster faster
I wonder if that guy was a deal breaker
fill er up take it to the top it's like
[ __ ] food Jenga yeah just keep
putting it in her mouth in pinata yeah
good lord there's a shooter open with a
rifle that's perfect but that shirt do
you definitely had to have something to
do with it
well you could tell it's hard to you
know humming I think in
shirt in the man was reeling so I think
he was getting he was getting lost
inside of the shirt I like that he
committed to it
oh dude he went on he went hard man and
after that he had to go take a break he
said he'd been through too much for that
night and clocked out good lord what
it's like I'm breakable yeah just like a
hero amongst us
well that's eating in New Orleans man I
mean all just [ __ ] crazy bro you know
it's crazy I spent a lot of time that
I'm not welcome back I don't think but
and what happened you get an argument
with somebody about a recipe now I got
in a fight about I got a football
argument online and and that was people
got a little upset at me was that after
the Minnesota miracle or not before it
um it was after the Minnesota miracle or
no no it was after the Saints of that
call where they got robbed that pass
interference no call yeah and I made
some side comment and we got a question
about it it's semi related to getting in
Tiff's about sports okay this guy said
okay just living in those room
what up do what up Nik Gang Gang what
uh-uh
I got a question I basically got this
guy and a [ __ ] broken cheek for
wearing a Pittsburgh pirate hat repping
them Stiller's Pittsburgh I mean but a
question is Nick I know you talk a lot
of [ __ ] about the Minnesota sports when
your roller blading down Reno living in
those Randy Moss colpepper days but uh
my question is have you ever been hit or
someone tried to fight you for talking
[ __ ] about sports or something and same
for you Thea what about them Saints yeah
oh and by the way I don't live here is
where I work just to clarify cuz I know
it looks like [ __ ] no man it looks fun
dude I'm sorry that's why ya turn into a
black eye it looks like dude that's yeah
yeah dude right there yeah that was that
was a shiner dude yeah that was a
[ __ ] pop um I have other questions
about that was it a sucker punch or was
it [ __ ] face to face where this dude
came in stealth that looks like sucker
punch that looks like it's a black that
looks like I've ever seen hits burger
maker
guy dodge it came back catch yeah yeah
yeah that Punxsutawney Phil hit him with
that [ __ ] surprise gopher do that oh
look Don
mingi how are you to answer your
question I have I being for a Minnesota
we're a little bit more docile very
docile so I don't really get in
fisticuffs when I'm out and about I
don't really talk [ __ ] and I know that
sounds like a [ __ ] move in person yeah
I mean like all talk [ __ ] and then I'll
be like okay I'll buy you a beer you
know what I mean I mean not to say that
I you know fighting is just I'm not
gonna not gonna get into that shit's I'm
on camera this is the [ __ ] the Brad
Pitt right here oh yeah ant of fart
jokes yeah no but I I just it's not at
that point like worth where I'm gonna go
into blows you know I mean I like just
popping off but it's like you know to me
Minnesota we don't like escalate it that
much
now what state does escalate it I think
every other one yeah every other state
you know I'll say this to you Minnesota
is the one place where I feel like I
have the toughest time with audiences
there they're just they almost don't
want to engage too much they're almost
just being nice in a lot of ways like
like they're loving the show I feel like
but they just sometimes they don't want
to go to outside with her with
imaginations cuz it's just I don't know
they kind of just stay in some zones I
feel it depends upon the crowd that you
get but for the most part they're
they're always with you they're good
crowds they get it you can kind of
challenge them I mean I'm not my comedy
is always just me but like other comics
that like really push that they've
always done well like Doug Stanhope
always has a great fan base and
following there and you know he pushes
his audience I've seen it for since I
started you know for 20-plus years yeah
and you know there's certain comics
where that's their thing and you know
Minnesota crowds like they welcome that
stuff I mean it does push like certain
people you can tell they're like oh
alright that was okay mister I tell ya
nah no yes snickerdoodles for you bucko
or you take all right but uh yeah so to
answer your question I haven't really
gotten into like blows and stuff but I
mean I did go to an Eagles game and
there are a couple games I've gone to
where I was like I mean I went to an
Eagles game with like a bunch of my
buddies from Philly but like that like
that matters yeah but I did see I go to
Eagles stadium for the first time
it's called but wouldn't say you go Sam
you know I'm talking about the nest I
think they call it yeah and so I go and
I walk in and I see this Philly Eagles
fan Lincoln field and let's lamp is
active this guy's at the field his hats
like this he's probably 30 but he looks
like he's 15 and it sounds like this
guy's cigarette in the stadium might be
David Akers and might be David
so he's chewing out this is nice Ram for
the play in the Rams not a rival this is
early in the season this guy's in the
students face in a Rams Jersey the guy
polite quiet and skies like 4k Rams will
[ __ ] you for [ __ ] breakfast
[ __ ] watch just Ennis toots grill and
this guy is just polite just taking it
and thus out that's the first thing I
saw us okay here we go yeah and you know
I don't know it was pretty interesting
do you think that they are because I'm
alone with the Philly one night does the
first timer when took a place called
Manny onk and I ended up in an attic
somebody said it was a nightclub it was
just some guy's attic you know who had
some [ __ ] hot electronics right and
every between every song of Nelly that
they would play they would play the
Philadelphia Eagles fight song and then
like they kept saying who wants to [ __ ]
these slammed pigs and it was like some
kind of you know rubenesque type of
young you know women you know right of
age women legal women but who were
trying to just do sex with everybody and
it was extremely alarming to me man I
felt very scared and this was supposed
to be out of fun at a night time at a
nightclub you know right uh Philly is
the conundrum I have a great shows there
my fan base there is awesome everybody's
so cool yeah been great to me but it is
one of those places where like I you've
got to just know and go out with people
yeah I mean I've had friends in from
Philly out in Philly and this is my
favorite thing and I don't know many
places like this with like I'll be like
yeah what's up now again Nick what's
going on right now we'll do a shot [ __ ]
[ __ ] and really it's my buddies from
feeling like well part of Philly
and if you're from like some other part
that's like right outside yeah or maybe
outside but not in part of like and look
what are you fighting a fart of this
[ __ ] guy yeah like I want to do a
show in Philly just called this [ __ ]
guy
there's all my friends from Philly
anytime somebody says something that
they don't like or approve of they're
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] guy yeah what
is [ __ ] what is [ __ ] pay
you're not from Philly like minutes
study could be like I'm from the border
and the [ __ ] under a lake
five hours outside of Minnesota yeah
baby like oh yeah I know where that is
yeah really like the [ __ ] way I know
that [ __ ] black the [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
out of here you [ __ ] leper
it's [ __ ] leper yeah everybody yeah
Philly everybody's mother has a [ __ ]
neck tat everybody's you know got a neck
brace that's a new hot thing on a lot of
these chicks out there too [ __ ] sexy
do you know the neck brace with a
leopard print you know dude I was about
Philly man if you go up by Broad Street
up by Temple University yeah it's a
little nicer okay yeah and I saw a bird
up there [ __ ] selling coke one time
dude I'm not even joking they had a crow
and it had a little bag of [ __ ] rocks
hooked to its own I know I've seen that
dude I was [ __ ] in Philly one time
and I saw cops surrounding a birdhouse
and I was a bird crack house and they
had guns drawn and everything dude there
was [ __ ] five Birds in there just
flipping yay nice you're just making it
[ __ ] rain yeah but Phil I mean I like
Philly I have a blast I mean I go out
and [ __ ] trying dude yeah like New
Orleans I love I was bummed because
people got mad at me but I it's funny
cuz I sided with that call so I like
made some joke about like yeah okay
Vikings wobbling on people like [ __ ] you
and they're like me better not come back
Normans yeah not one oh I was like
whatever bro I've [ __ ] go to New
Orleans I love it and I agreed with the
call you get the state's got [ __ ] rod
I'm a sports fan like I'm logical like
when I see something I'm like okay if
somebody wins and they play good I give
it up to I'm not one was [ __ ]
delusional [ __ ] loons yeah that's
just blind and it's like no [ __ ] you I'm
like no you guys got robbed the Saints
got rod that wasn't money that's what
I'm most insane no calls I've ever seen
in my life yeah do you think of the
league in some weird way had it out for
him you think that was just the way it
shut down I don't know again that's the
craziest thing I've ever seen
yeah I mean if that's he'll except for
the
Minnesota miracle was also the craziest
thing the way that the guy just sort of
even when you watch her back on tape
great play for Minnesota and they
deserved that they deserved and no doubt
but even you watching Mike on tape it's
like it was like 2 percent chance of
whatever body movement or whatever
happened in that moment I've watched it
5 million times yeah here it is right
here that's my boy Case Keenum what it
started Diggs obviously I mean I I don't
know play really if you look at it now
there's been a lot better plays have you
seen that got a Damian Lillard hit that
three-point of the other that was no
that was last night yeah way better
here it is I don't think well the
defender didn't realize where the ball
was so he didn't realize Diggs was gonna
jump like that so you can see it right
here right so he thought he was going in
right at his waist which would've been a
legit all right he didn't realize the
ball was in here his head was down so he
didn't realize so I felt bad for that
dude right away yeah I was things went
bad after that I think some of those
things happen with his family it's been
a tough time for that dude so yeah see
like somebody that I don't pile on a guy
like that I don't like robbing and I was
hat ecstatic you Devils looking for that
guy poor guy open up its the police now
I'm just joking it to me I'm just
busting in a moun episode here dude nick
nick swardson his wild isn't he can you
imagine him on a trapeze I can't but God
I really really would love to see it I
mean I would go see that Barnum and
Bailey and straight [ __ ] circus all
day long today's episode is brought to
you by Bud elegance now we have a man
coming on the podcast today who
everybody knows that he's really if any
adult should still be wearing a diaper
that's non senior citizen it's this
tricky pasty bad boy himself and that
boy I'm talking about is Nicolas
Swardson and this dude I mean you want
to talk about diarrhea this guy really
is a jean-claude van diarrhea you know
I'm saying he'll kick the [ __ ] right out
of himself he's that kind of guy well
bud elegance is a natural cleaning foam
show you that bottle right there that's
18.6 fluid ounces
you hear that that's that but cleaner
but elegance is that natural cleansing
foam it brings you the luxury and
elegance of a bidet with the convenience
a toilet paper imagine not having to
have it have a imagine not having to
have a huge bidet installed you got a
little bit day in your hand apply but
elegance moisturizing cleansing foam -
toilet paper and - wet clean and dry
your private areas both front and back
some people just do one private dude do
them both front and back ladies - go on
brush your booties off better than both
dry toilet paper and wet wipes
cost-effective anti-inflammatory
soothing keep your hands dry does not
harm sewer systems you're not going to
hear your pipes belts when you drop this
thing in it at all at and it's
eco-friendly
get bud elegance enjoy and enjoy a clean
soothing shower fresh feeling after
every trip to the bathroom but elegance
is available right now on amazon.com for
10% off and free shipping use promo code
10 Theo von 1 0 th EO vo n that's the
number one the number zero Theo von
that's 10% off and free shipping using
10 diovan for bead elegance B ID eleg
ance at amazon.com get that fresh bottom
hitter what about B ever would you ever
run a bar it seemed like you would open
one I wouldn't want to open a bar for my
whole life
and what's the name give a name up for
yet this past weekend really yeah the
bar big Nick's dick shop as you call it
it's a shop yeah dude I want to pitch a
show to you and I want to see if you'd
be on it with me okay it's called
gravity hunters okay
okay I'm intrigued you and me okay go
around in a van looking for gravity
okay it's gravity a rapper no it's hot
no it's not a black person dude calm
down
I just said rapper oh sorry we had a
girl named gravity Jackson at our school
when I was growing up but this I went to
your school that's why was reference no
it's an actual gravity actual force to
pull a force onto on land I guess nature
but that's the thing is it we heard a
rumor that it isn't I don't know let's
have some Ryan Bosworth
hey buzz it seems like so since you
retired you you got into some crazy
stuff you come on the bunny ranch okay
and that's another episode of weekend at
Bosworth um yeah I'll [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
find some gravity what would we do when
we find it well that's the thing man you
don't know oh sit so it's kind of a
silly idea I guess but no I like it
don't get down on yourself we'll do it
we'll do it on the Lifetime network yeah
yeah where's the life network for men
first of all I don't know it's a good
question remember how good TV shows used
to be on lifetime any channel how would
a heaven remember that just the 10 of us
yeah
all of that eight eight eight Mile House
yeah oh just the 10 of us yeah it was
one man nine kids bro
wife gave up on him left him with nine
[ __ ] kids man what what when was that
what era was a 1980s man ladies what was
his show was there a show that you ever
got like pinched for that you bailed on
I don't know what I mean see you ever
got picked for you wanted a bet that you
like paused on no I didn't pass on any
shows but I was really picky with TVs
all the sitcoms were so [ __ ] corny
yeah
and so I I was up for a handful of shows
ever I read four Dawson's Creek back in
the day for the role of Pacey oh yeah
but I was like youngish
but I read for that it would have been a
totally different show though huh
it would have been way different dukes I
was on roller skates dude I met that guy
when I was a University of Arizona I met
that guy it seems corner of them he was
like at a bar was like one of the first
like celebrities I'd ever seen except
Michael Lannon like allegedly came in
like I caught fire in our town one time
but um this was like one of the first
letter he's ever seen he was at a bar
and all the like chicks were in knew him
and stuff like that and I was just
jealous and I called him like I went
outside my friends and called him like a
[ __ ] and then laughs that's cool yeah I
was kind of yeah I'm gonna feel bad
about it now he's just a guy at a bar
you know I was just jealous yeah I can
tell your Twitter you're like picking at
your fingernails like you just still
remember that memory no shell want to go
back I wish I could haymaker at his dead
what so a [ __ ] scrotal haymaker ha ha
yeah I was up for a [ __ ] a bunch that
70s show they were developing the show
and I was up for Ash and Cooter's part
no yeah I was in the mix for that dude
and then what and I was [ __ ] arrested
development too
really yeah but I was in the mix for a
handful of things but do you you were
the thing so these were the things you
only went out for that you really want
like it we're into at least whenever you
see the scripts cuz people must send you
stuff all the time people send me [ __ ]
yeah I don't yeah I don't really look at
a lot of stuff summer I just don't
I wanna I'm at the point I've been this
way luckily for a while but I'm a writer
too so I just want to create my own
stuff I have my own voice I my own [ __ ]
you know what I mean would you ever do
some real ass [ __ ] I'll do some realized
[ __ ] like a gravity show yeah yeah yeah
actually yeah I'd [ __ ] with gravity what
about something kind of like a rural
type of uh you know kind of a No Country
for Old Men sort of meets Sanford and
Son whites though hmm that's interesting
so it's no country for Bryan Callen yeah
yeah I go you said old man ya know I
would do whatever I just want to do
something like that's interesting do you
want to still though do you think you
solve the energy for cuz sometimes it's
like do you have the bandwidth to do
that or do you just like kind of touring
once in a while I like you know
I kind of want a TV show just as I can
stay at home it's like traveling I'm you
know I guess up 42 I've done this 22
years Wow
over 22 and uh you know I just like want
to kind of stay home I can't like I
don't know how you are but these tours I
look at [ __ ] you know our friends
like Sebastian D'Elia all these dudes
Brian Regan all these guys that like
[ __ ] two or Gaffigan these guys go I
see them on Instagram and they're
[ __ ] yeah I'm going back just tour
dates where I'm like what enough [ __ ]
the area yeah that's what it gives me it
gives me bile reah yeah but you know I
just don't know how like that's just
insane and it's so much but you know
they crush it and I just for me I don't
know if I could do that so I'm trying to
I try to find that balance of like pop
out to a movie and then like hoping I
get another TV show the new movie was it
is it pretty good can you tell it's good
when you're doing it ya know it's funny
the cast is great this girl Lauren
lapkus yeah she's funny hilarious she's
a plays opposite Spade he plays more
like the straight man and she's a
brilliant but the whole cast there's so
many good people rob shiners in it he's
hilarious so like you can tell and they
let us improvise and obviously no David
Wells so we work well off each other but
I was like pale and like gained weight
for the part I look like a [ __ ]
Michelin like miss Farley huh oh dude
yeah swing-and-a-miss Farley broke good
oh let's get into some questions you
have something came in for Nicholas mhm
hey Theo hey Nick this is John from
Cleveland Ohio that's good I got a
question for Nick yo he's constantly
talking about diarrhea and farting is
there any story behind that any crazy a
childhood memory of [ __ ] yourself or
fartin thanks guys Gang Gang in game
brother um alright to answer that
question cuz you do bring it up a lot
I'll be like one time you told me
someone should farting your butt which
was the craziest thing I've ever heard
of my life Rowan no joke one of the
funniest things that because it seems so
impossible
yeah that's not possible it seems like
really next level but here's the thing
about it to answer your question because
people I've heard that before but like
people
mad Lagoon thought it was some a party
tutorial like yet [ __ ] grow up like
you're still talking about this here's
the [ __ ] point I'm in on the joke I
know it's stupid here's the annoys me
about people something oh it's [ __ ]
stupid yeah I know it's [ __ ] stupid
that's why I'm laughing about it I did a
joke early on way back in the day car
about my cat it's diarrhea hmm I took
him to the vet and the vets like what
have you been feeding him and I'm like
diarrhea and that's like way back in
there and it made me laugh because it
was so stupid and so then I just started
like I would have like diarrhea jokes
and then I made it a thing when I was
like every special when I have a joke
about diarrhea yeah every joke I wanna I
mean every special when I like a fart
joke and it's only like few and far
between my last special on Netflix which
is on comics of the world I do like I'll
[ __ ] your pants story but so I'm doing
it as a joke to like it just makes me
laugh and then the people that get it
they know like I'm clearly just doing it
because it's so over the top like my
couple specials ago was called seriously
who farted mm-hmm it was just solely for
the [ __ ] I'm just bracing out immature
and dumb it is because I just want
people to have to say that and then I
read a review of my special and some guy
goes I love this special it's one of my
favorites the only annoying thing is I
have to keep telling people with the
title so they're like what made you
laugh so he's like I saw this thing is
called seriously who farted and then I
just I laugh at people having to say
that and I'm like I'm the off-chance
never get nominated for something some
old crusty dudes gotta be up there like
and the specials are seriously who
farted and like so if you're of that
mindset then it makes it hopefully that
makes you laugh because you know that
I'm know that it's [ __ ] stupid
I see see your head what am I gonna talk
about like I'm not yeah political we
might talk politics yeah I think of a
[ __ ] everybody's diarrhea if you're
[ __ ] Republican or Democrat yeah you
[ __ ] rock at the D Reed oh dude
you're on [ __ ] Lake Deary dude gay or
straight black white asian you know
everybody rock it's the d-r-e
dude I think I've never Jiri splatted
dude in a brother one time I was in the
urinal in the stall you know doing what
I do right number two it yeah and this
they had a brother in there and he beat
on the wall at one point he's like he
was on the phone of course and he beat
on the wall at one point is like hey
don't let me get
courtesy flush you know and I'd never
heard that apparently in the black
community you get that courtesy flush
yeah
no courtesy flush is good mine's just
straight peppermint splatty oh wow
that's green Wow vile right that's vile
did you get this from traveling do the
worse is Airport bathroom Oh when you
have splatter from all over the world oh
you've got a [ __ ] Universal [ __ ]
stench from everybody traveling from oh
it's a Unabomber I said it's him in the
basic gray brother [ __ ] people think
about me meeting from all over the world
and putting all their diary in the same
pipe yeah it's a it's a [ __ ] whole
new world well you know some people say
that God farted humanity to Adam and Eve
into the universe that's what they say
sometimes yeah I I believe it uh uh yeah
I don't know who said that but I think
it was in The Truman Show I'm not sure
I'll look it up I think it was yeah
let's take another call that came in
here for Nicholas I'm just a quick
question what does the Adam Sandler
smell like because those might be the
Dark Arts gang gang Oh gang man so yeah
what does Adam Sandler what does he wear
a cologne is he tall what is he like he
wears [ __ ] Gatorade oh I can see that
yeah he plays basketball the time he
just douses himself he's played a lot of
Hoops
he does play a lot of Hoops man he's
deceivingly athletic oh he's really
athletic he's got a really good fadeaway
jump shot he surprises the [ __ ] out of
people dude he's like the mess he's like
the white master P yeah exactly
and Master a yeah after a Rea they call
him but yeah so but it's stressful
playing with him because he plays
[ __ ] all the time so we're filming he
likes to take a break and play hoop but
then we're filming so it's like if you
[ __ ] hurt him I've given him some
[ __ ] knots he gets pissed [ __ ]
grill he doesn't get pissed but it's
like you know it's on camera shoot
around it yeah Zoe
you know it's just everyone's scared to
like really play hard defense on them
yeah because if you roll his ankle yeah
there is
I own this game is this a dan Patrick
yes dan Patrick oh god it's him Patrick
any good I've never played with Dan
looks like a real [ __ ] out there dude
look what it look what he's doing
yeah look it out I'm draining it
draining what he means an employer way
man hoarder Roy's was on that dog yeah
this is look at Dan brick this is Alex
why guys in pants shooting out in a
parking lot called a New England
basketball okay
middle-aged to old New England
basketball what do you guys on that guy
all day what's something you miss a lot
about growing up and I miss about I miss
growing up all the time I miss being a
kid um I miss yeah I miss my [ __ ]
paper route dude I would [ __ ] I mean I
could still a blonde it you were like
Chris Elliot I was like paperboy dude
number that show Chris hell you did with
the paper route
get a life amazing good I don't know I
miss saw I just miss not giving a [ __ ]
dude I miss summer nights I miss just
like I miss like going out like staying
up late was like a big thing yeah when
you would be like you'd have a slumber
party noon your buddies and even wait
and it would be like 10 or 11 o'clock at
night and you [ __ ] go you wouldn't
even know what to do yeah this is what
like me and my friends were in sixth
grade rhythm summer party and this is
kind of [ __ ] rug we didn't know what
we were doing movie we knew that we'd
was a thing but we didn't have access to
it or what the [ __ ] how to get it right
went sixth grade so we rolled up T and
we rolled up tea and coffee filters that
look like joints yeah we went out and
broke into a golf course that was a big
thing
oh yeah we're on the putting green and
stuff T and then we people thought they
felt it but nobody felt [ __ ] oh yeah
some was all Earl great up everybody's
[ __ ] camera music oh we had this guy
named Jeff saavy AK and he had a gas
leak at his house right but we didn't
know so we'd go over there and sleep for
no joke 30 hours doobie fall asleep on
Friday wake up on [ __ ] Sunday right
because they had a CMO leak or whatever
it is
carbon monoxide carbon dioxide so we get
over there do it and like bro you go
through the kitchen his mom would be
like asleep making a [ __ ] salad bro
like we didn't know what was going on I
thought the family was all on drugs on
pills you know whatever inadvertently
on early ludes right so then we came out
and uh and we were all excited about
that brown fram that's what you got in
Louisiana it was just [ __ ] gutter
somebody [ __ ] grew it in their ass
bro you know and [ __ ] let it ferment
under their nuts bro so people would
always say yeah I got some weed but
really like you didn't have any and then
you got to like nighttime people like
break out your [ __ ] weed man she'd
have to get something fake so of course
we got a reg you know that's what
everybody got like yeah yeah looked like
weed then we'd roll it up got him [ __ ]
okay and then come back in and like
everybody just pretend they were high
cuz nobody would admit that it was right
and we want to miss them and they were
just smoking some booty moths yeah yeah
just roof rifling up some booty Moss
booty mo yeah I know I was trying to
explain to somebody that we would get
weed off the train tracks yeah we would
go and then it would just grow wild and
we would just sit there and pick leaves
and dry them out and it was like barely
a high but we thought we were [ __ ]
full - oh yeah we weren't doing [ __ ] my
first weekend up at I went to University
of Minnesota actually my [ __ ] my first
weekend there we were at a bus stop
waiting to go back to the st. Paul
campus and a homeless guy was talking to
us and we were all wasting [ __ ] and he
sold his shrooms and I buddies come up
the next weekend and we sat there and we
ate him and the guy just told us like
portobellos or something I don't know
for 70 bucks 70 bucks for a quad I
thought I had the best deal ever my
friends who drove up we're pissed do
that that's how [ __ ] went down yeah but
we're throwing up people would always
scare me with fake [ __ ] it was wheels
get look [ __ ] I dealt drugs for a
little while oh yeah yeah I dealt drugs
for 40 minutes but when I [ __ ] got so
I couldn't handle the pressure ro if I
can call the cops on myself I did one
deal and then I got in trouble with some
kids mom and you lived on the edge bro I
can't believe you shared that holy [ __ ]
you there's gonna be cops on the way
over here right now yeah what would you
get this dude out it he just get out of
the jail holy [ __ ] hardcore II yeah he
just uh they just he just closed down a
Cheesecake Factory
come on chef
yeah that's a real hard this guys
[ __ ] dealing dude your drummer at
Chuck E Cheese holy [ __ ]
damn dude I know man I seem like a guy
that threat or really uh he actually he
just worked a double at the Disney Store
earlier so he's holy [ __ ] G got 86 from
a juice bar
holy thank you go back to Jamba Juice
bro bro that guy used to work he got he
used to work at one of those
build-a-bears trouble for toughen up to
fat dude this dude's on the edge dude
holy [ __ ]
God you a farmer a pottery bondage and
it's [ __ ] throwing [ __ ] hay out of
your [ __ ] pubes
wow man yeah you've been using heavy
glaze over that Color Me Mine bro or
what's been going on
back off the kiln your little twink dude
get the [ __ ] out you give out any size
at lady Foot Locker oh no I don't even
know what that means
that guy wears a size four [ __ ]
woman's shoe bro Sweden you're good
here's what I'm saying bro is this we
would come back in from Britannia
Morocco
so we Dowe now we're all inside having a
Bert in we're high even though each one
of us knows we're not right and we had
this one guy between us he was not the
brightest dude brothers do name Joffrey
right and so first of all if you live in
the south in a simple town don't give
your son a crazy name okay yeah because
people always will call him they call
them racial slurs all the time you know
they'd be like Oh Joffrey that [ __ ]
[ __ ] or [ __ ] you know or they do
something like that out and I'm not
saying those things and my listeners
know that you know but I'm telling a
story yeah and so anyway yah we all come
back in and we're like I'm like my
buddies I can't even see right he's just
standing on the porch pretending you
can't find his way back into the house
Joffrey doesn't know how to be hi goes
into their kitchen breaks a [ __ ]
mirror with his [ __ ] head oh my god
it's not even a high thing I know he
didn't it was like
bro and it wasn't even weed and that's
when I knew something was [ __ ] wrong
with that dude
yeah that's often yeah that's back in
the day when we die I don't yeah that's
a smoked oregano more like but we're all
like okay it wasn't even weed yeah he's
like I'm so [ __ ] I pop open you up
and say yes you press relax guy with a
small dick obviously calm down
dude yeah Joffre dude where is he now
oh who knows maybe who knows he won't
return any about texts I've tried to
reach out to him all right well pray so
but uh yeah I was the opposite I mean
when I got introduced to like other [ __ ]
like we got [ __ ] popped off I remember
somebody offered me up for 20 this shows
and Denver doing Red Rocks which was
dope and somebody offered me mushrooms
and I can't do that stuff anymore but I
did back in the day so I took I do your
mushroom story my buddy's brother went
to school in Colorado came back to
Minnesota need a garbage bag small
garbage bag of mushrooms that were Rogue
rogue from the [ __ ] manure oh yeah a
bison [ __ ] those are the hard hitters
nothing that's what Rogan [ __ ] eats
like cereal now oh geez wakes up like
[ __ ] Wheaties yeah that's just Dookie
shroom just goes into his [ __ ] a
thigh and his neck or whatever Oh
somebody said he had a couple of calf
blood earlier they saw him sitting on
the side of the [ __ ] interstate yeah
he drinks oh like that
he's got spanked he's out with his calf
blood like fancy [ __ ] cow goes Moo
[ __ ] oh just as somebody said they did
that they saw him just crushing up
t-cells and [ __ ] snorting lines oh
yeah dude [ __ ] man Wow guy so we started
just taking handfuls of mushrooms and
working like 15 and I think we tallied
that we eaten about 5 to 6 grams and we
were like gonna go to a movie where my
friend's car we're starting it likes
high as [ __ ] and I was like I should
have forgot my wallet I mean which is
like a big deal oh it's huge it's best
when you're tripping right they take
everything our high schools I don't have
any money
yeah so it was in my house I did go back
and I started to get high and I go and
like sneak into my room and take my
wallet and
I go to pee really quick so my mom
doesn't hear me and I pee and then all
of a sudden I start realizing everybody
knows this from like when you do [ __ ]
like that it's kicking in everybody
knows the kick in where you're like and
here we so I try to sneak out my mom
goes Nicolas and I'm like she was really
doing aegyo
forgot my wallet that's what I said I
probably said yeah
who knows so she goes hey come here I go
into her room and she's sitting on her
bed oh this is not a joke I still
remembers she had neon snowflakes all
over her [ __ ] body in her face so she
goes Nicolas I'm like she was what what
are you doing and I got I have my wallet
I forgot it and I start laughing you
know that hi laughs especially like on
mushrooms where it's just you're like
you might as well be in a haunted house
it's just like so she's like what the
[ __ ]
so I'm not telling her I'm on [ __ ]
Dukey [ __ ] yeah Hazuki Boomers they
call Dookie boomers yeah so she goes
what's so funny and I go I hurt I go I
heard the funniest joke and I'm just
laughing which apparently it had to have
been the funniest joke ever written in
the history of human race because I was
laughing like [ __ ] Jekyll buddy when
they're laughing I heard the funniest
joke and then doesn't tell him what now
she goes what was it and I go I have no
idea then I threw myself under my own
bus and then I just panicked and just
walked away she's confused but she's a
Minnesota woman she had no idea what was
going on but yeah that was my mushroom
first mushroom experience dude I got so
[ __ ] up one time out on buddy's house
dude uh and he was [ __ ] up dude he had
to go lay in the back bro and at one
point he was told us take my skin off
I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out like bro
we're not doing good you know yeah and
uh and then I went out in my car for
some reason took all my clothes off in
the back of my car and I was and I had
like a Ford Escort it was a hatchback
two-door and someone had stole my
passenger seat right so what yeah
yeah yeah dude and I try to get out
through the front like by pushing the
seat up the seat hits the horn it's the
middle of the night my buddy's mom's
driveway some he comes running out bro
he is also completely [ __ ] naked row
and we got naked in separate places and
then met up together naked that's how
good those mushrooms were these weren't
those [ __ ] keep your clothes on fungi
you know what I'm saying so we meet up
dude he's like he's trying to be all
quiet even meanwhile there's a horn
going of our car I had a couple of
brothers with me right and this woman
brothers were kind of novice in like you
know society a little bit a little bit
more when I was growing up so I'm on
mushrooms I didn't tell anybody you know
and I got to my black friends this guy
named Mike Tyson everybody called him
booboo Tyson cuz his brother tried to
burn down the house and his leg got all
cooked one of his legs and then there's
something guy named Chris Jones who was
real quiet but he would let me drive him
around he would go [ __ ] chicks you know
so anyway I decided I was like oh we
pulled her from the side of the highway
to smoke some weed and I was already so
[ __ ] up off these mushrooms and so
then we're about to leave and I tell
them that the car will start right even
though it will you know I know this you
notice I keep pretending like it won't
start so now dude it's middle of the
night bro darkest [ __ ] they're out
looking under the hood bro there's no
lights or anything anywhere there's no
way to see anything [ __ ] looking
under the car I keep saying [ __ ] fix
it man we got to get the [ __ ] out of
here tearing at it like it's a [ __ ]
Rubik's Cube like no idea like [ __ ] dark
I must have lost two pounds in [ __ ]
water weight out of my body from crying
laughing I just
making him give back out and try to fix
it oh my god man I feel bad man what uh
but it was fun man I told him later what
had happened I felt bad about it but how
long did you wait until you told him
probably 15 years that's a good question
that's a good question
cuz that's yeah what were you like in
school I was a [ __ ] nightmare
were you oh my god was terrible I was
like really smart kid but I just didn't
give a [ __ ] yes the cool seemed a little
ridiculous to me I like being friends
with like the sick lady dude I would get
a boner and go into the office and tell
him that I was sick and I'm just
pointing my boner audience
15:16 you know what did you see - it's a
nice you would give me ice should put
ice in your piece you see I said her no
no she would give me two bag if you
little pack not a little pack I mean two
bags there's a [ __ ] help you give you
half a cube yeah she cut it happens like
you that's [ __ ] weird I got expelled
from school for four times I got
expelled this is true story what
happened to you man you see Mike I don't
know I was [ __ ] people are like think
that but I was [ __ ] reckless - yeah
my friends were all they I had some
hardcore friends and my good Trent
Reznor what the [ __ ] did you - yeah I
was [ __ ] Trevor your friends man do
we were stealing cars and she were like
14 friends and gangs and [ __ ] oh oh but
I got expelled for point fire alarms we
could go smoke a cigarette yeah but it
was like a 3,000 compound school mm-hmm
so dude empty out the whole [ __ ]
school just so we could rip butts and we
go back in yeah I got pinched twice then
I smoked a blunt in school so I went to
the auditorium me and my buddies slide
up a fat blind and this is the era when
like Cypress Hill came out at the Eagles
game on dude
so we light up a blunt cops kick in the
door we get handcuffed we get like filed
out in front of everybody - so this job
it like serious [ __ ] crazy
yeah like what they do trying but I got
court-ordered rehab after that real and
then I got a I got [ __ ] I put a sign
on a substitute teachers butt
and I got thrown out for that too [ __ ]
so sorry
oh we were [ __ ] rug we stole a car
what kind of car was it we it was cold
out so we were just we had a screwdriver
and we would [ __ ] Jimmy cars yeah and
now we stole it and now my buddy goes
look in the glove compartment see if
there's anything open the glove
compartment and there was a [ __ ]
rosary and a Bible and an ID card it was
a priests car and I was like get me the
[ __ ] out of this car my buddy's like
dude chill I could get me the [ __ ] out
of here
so I mean diarrhea so me and my me and
my other buddy Josh sounds like a real
winner Josh was cool nice cool he was
yeah he was Catholic no so he freaked
out and I was really religious but I was
religious enough I was like get me on
his stolen priests car we got out my
buddies take it go joyriding bleep they
get [ __ ] pulled over but I'll [ __ ]
Jew beat up they went [ __ ] down
really yeah they got clipped I never got
Pitt always like knew what I was doing
yeah you know what I mean like yeah I
had the wherewithal my buddies set up
the other day I did a show Minnesota and
he came to the show and he told me it
was like did he always like had another
sense of like this is going bad yeah
yeah yeah one time some cops told us to
follow him to the police station we were
under arrest right my buddy's driving
and another buddies in the passenger
seat I'm in the backseat at a stoplight
I'm like hey guys I'm I'm out
i'm just gonna jet and like what the
[ __ ] dude we're like following the cop
right you're like what the [ __ ] dude
we're gonna we're gonna get arrested
that's like yeah I'm not you know I'm
I'm gonna just walk up I was like my
homie I'm Niall I'm just gonna kind of
slip out casually when you guys leave
this stop like nothing I did and they
[ __ ] went and got arrested yeah I
guess it sometimes just just wherewithal
like oh this is not gonna go well right
here on mouth yeah I did this this is my
claim of like serious get out
senses I've told this story before on
some [ __ ] but uh I'll just tell it real
quick
so me my buddies had a posse and we
lived in this neighborhood in st. Paul
and there was a abandoned house across
the alley from my buddy's place so we
went in this house and had a party we're
like 14 abandoned or for lease it was
abandoned okay
like it but somebody bought it but it
was like it's big old house yeah right
off the train tracks oh yeah so we gonna
have a party we're sitting at chicks got
booze he got smokes so one of my buddies
he was just rogue his parents like
weren't around yeah you know both UPS
drivers yeah yeah the yeah they're both
[ __ ] packages oh yeah oh he were in
the middle of party we're all buzzed he
takes a [ __ ] Molotov cocktail
we were defacing spray-painting
everything this guy goes Star Wars rogue
one takes it throws it fire we all dip
out we run our crew go across the I to
my friend's house and we're like holy
[ __ ] and we crash in the household
we [ __ ] the next day wake up it's on
the news there's cops all over the
neighborhood
everywhere somebody calls us to like
from another house they're like dude
there's cops all over the place we're
looking out the windows there's like 30
cops surrounding it like we find out
that there's there everywhere
so my buddy's like let's just chill here
and I go no we gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here they're gonna find us because we
they know that we're like the
neighborhood ruffians yeah yeah so I'm
like we got to get out of here they're
like no stay here and I go no so I go to
him we're all starter jackets and chains
and yeah so I go [ __ ] this I got you
have a collared shirt and goes yeah I
put on his dad's like shorts i cinch him
put on a collared shirt I got his you're
down of a tennis racket and he goes yeah
take the tennis racket fix my hair walk
out the back of my tennis racket walk
down the alley there's like five cops at
the end of the alley watching me and I
go hey what's up officer and they're
like glaring at me and they're like hey
what's going on
city bus pulls up I jump on it so I go
back to my house I'm like holy [ __ ]
I found out after the fact cops busted
in and clipped all my privates
15 minutes later or 20 minutes whatever
it was a little bit later they [ __ ]
had narrowed it down that it was our
house they didn't see me coming out of
the house I wasn't like that but I just
walking on now with my tennis racket and
they all got [ __ ] yeah you look
nailed I love how you look so normal
these local cops yeah they're like who's
this complete tennis you know tennis
court and then just playing tennis on
the train tracks I'm just hitting
against a moving train like [ __ ] a
vertullo
just [ __ ] getting after it dear
they're like the students [ __ ] gonna
go to Wimbledon yeah you can play tennis
anywhere but at it I've survived some
[ __ ] it seemed like you've been through
a lot man too much that's why it settled
on diarrhea farting even it out but I
like it man I gotta feed my your nice
guy I do too man we're gonna shut it
down I think huh Vic we've been through
a lot
yeah I think we got a lot of covered
anything less from you guys Jionni or
Nick no just a big fan work worked at
Acme for a year and Oh sick yes was I
around when you were there no you did
never pop in drunk or anything uh you
did like two shows one one night before
you started a tour okay I was like 2014
is pretty late okay word yeah that's all
I got did I want to do like an eastbound
and down type of show be fun uh yeah
[ __ ] yeah called gravity yeah gravity
hunters gravity hunters Oh anyway yeah
are you sticking around that's what it's
called
oh I like that punchline yeah it's good
walk em Nick at the end of your cards
apps that's the dark arts Nick Swardson
man thanks for coming and hanging out
yeah I do thanks for having me always
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]
oh but when I reach that round I'll
share this piece of my background I can
feel it in my bones
but it's gonna take
little town for me to set that parking
brake can let myself
[Music]